[Intro Music With Typewriter Effect]
[landing smack]
Hank: Good morning, John. It's Tuesday, February 20th.
Why do we always say "good morning"? It's never morning when I do this.
It's never morning when you see this. It's 2:18 here that means it's 4 o'clock there, Jesus
I need to get crackin. So the reason why my life sucks
Somewhere in here. I purchased three computers in the last week, two of them went back to Best Buy. One of them
I knew I was going to take back, the other one didn't have a second hard drive bay.
What kind of fancy new computer doesn't have a second hard drive bay?
Anyhow, the good news is this puppy's working now, and it's working for you
John Green. This is weird. It looks like I'm part of the machine
Like I've suddenly become the third hard drive. Wouldn't it be awesome
If Wikipedia could be in your brain.
I know Kung Fu.
Anyway, this computer now that it's work has been helping me do some Brotherhood 2.0. Projects
Most importantly we have our Myspace page which people are definitely already finding out about because we already have like 69 friends.
Don't know how that happened so fast. You posted a little thing on Sparks Fly Up and [snap] boom!
Okay, I sent a bulletin to all my friends too, but it's very exciting.
I'm glad to have friends, not that I didn't think I had friends before, not that I wasn't appreciative of our brotherhood 2.0. viewers before.
Hopefully, we've become gigantic on Myspace, and then all the Myspace people will become our friends.
I am going crazy about what my eyebrows are doing right now.
Whoa. Trying to get back into the swing of things here in Montana
But I haven't been able cause none of my computers work and my swing's dependent upon computers.
Roof has thrown off my groove,
They have off my groove!
Anyways I am absolutely amazed at the response to my survey.
That survey post has over 53 comments and over half of those are surveys and then on top
Of that there are surveys on Brotherhood2.com
There are surveys on other posts. There are serving some people's websites. There's audio surveys
There's video surveys - speaking of which who the heck is Tom?
John I did not know that we had a secret brother named Tom. He seems like a really nice guy though.
Hey, I'm Tom. I'm your third, brother. You've never met me or heard of me.
But I have a degree in chemical engineering and a wife and some kids.
Surprise! To add to my computer frustrations!
iMovie...
keeps locking up before I save!
Because I'm stupid and I haven't been saving so I'm just gonna do this and finish and say, "Bye."
Because I need to eat something,
and this is annoying! We'll see you tomorrow.